nintendo just dropped another trailer
for pokemon scarlet and pokemon violet
if you were hoping for some new info you
are absolutely in luck not only did we
get to see the new legendaries for the
first time ever but there's some big
news about how we can expect the
gameplay to work like this vid sub to
the channel and let's dive into
everything we know so far about pokemon
scarlet and pokemon violet
[Music]
right now we've got two trailers
released by the pokemon company the
first one simply showed off the new
three starters and confirmed the version
names there wasn't a lot of information
in that one however the more recent
trailer packs all the good stuff letting
us parse through these details in the
info available so first things first
let's get you all up to speed pokemon
scarlet and violet are the first in the
latest generation of pokemon games gen
9. we also know that they are both
coming out on the same day later this
year thanks to the new gameplay trailer
announcing the official date which is
november 18th 2022
both scarlet and violet will mark the
return of pokemon's classic dual version
release method you know like red and
blue gold and silver all the way to the
most recent brilliant diamond and
shining pearl which were remakes of gen
4's diamond and pearl the most recent
pokemon legends argue is strayed away
from this by being a standalone mainline
entry but it looks like we're back to
the typical duel version releases this
means we're definitely going to see the
return of some version exclusives gen 9
will also take place in a completely new
region this is expected since every new
mainline pokemon game features a new
region and they also tend to be based on
real world locations red and blue took
place in the kanto region of japan while
other regions like kalos alola and galer
take their inspiration from france
hawaii and the uk respectively now we
know there will be a new region but we
don't know the name yet however we can
reach an idea based on the debut trailer
many architectural and geographical
similarities to spain were noted
according to fans which makes this the
likely inspiration for scarlet and
violet the new starter names quaxly
sprigatito and fue coco also have
similarities to the spanish language now
in the first trailer we only saw the
three starters which of course fall into
the classic elemental trio of grass fire
and water now these typings have always
had this like rock paper scissors type
balance to them and they go all the way
back to the first game with game freak
leaving this mostly untouched personally
i get hyped the most when i see the
starters evolved forms however game
freak is still holding those cards
pretty close to their chest
we did however get to see some brand new
pokemon now we've got at least three
non-legendary new pokemon such as the
plant type smoliv the electric mouse
palmy because you know pokemon don't
have enough electric mouse pokemon
already right and the hilarious pig
leychonk not lebron not les mickey or
les salsa but le chunk it's real and he
looks and sounds kind of french too
it's a french pick yeah yeah you might
as well just end the video here he's
honestly perfect and in fact you know
what the legendaries i'm going off
script put late chunk on the cover or
give me some fan art of him at the
eiffel tower please make this happen
internet in all seriousness though le
chunk seems to be the standout for the
new pokemon revealed and according to
the official pokemon site lay chunk will
be used by your friend and rival named
mona you know speaking of the internet
when it comes to late chunk everyone's
been commenting on the tongue-in-cheek
references the game seems to be making
based on our slang after all referring
to lovable cats and dogs as being chunky
or even if you're cultured like me atomk
is basically an online pastime lei chunk
is more than welcome to the party
anecdotes aside we were able to catch a
glimpse of several other pokemon
returning for this region including the
classic fan favorites such as pikachu
meowth psyduck lucario and many others
curiously the trailer also showed the
hissuian variant of zoroark introduced
in pokemon legend's arceus now this is
cool because that opens the door up for
more history and variants but it is a
little confusing for me since those of
you who have played arceus will note
that the timeline of legends arceus is
largely different than that of the
modern pokemon games so it makes me
wonder were the events of legends arceus
namely the portal being open across
dimensions
did that have a reverse effect and
that's why we're seeing his informs in
the present day only time will tell
considering that there are hissuian
regional forms though this also opens
the door for gallerian forms and alolan
forms but we'll have to see in the
future what specifically will appear in
gen 9. lastly out of all the new pokemon
we've got the two legendaries corridon
and mariaden assuming that's how you
pronounce it and their design is pretty
sick the recurring theme seems to be
that of the past and the future are more
specifically tradition versus technology
and evolution it's an interesting
concept that is pretty apparent in the
design of the two legendary pokemon
karate and pokemon scarlet seem to be
representing the side of tradition while
at the same time marian and pokemon
violet have a more futuristic and
machine android style element to their
design you might have seen the trailer
and thought that there wasn't too much
that pushed the envelope forward
compared to prior gens still there are
some really intriguing features
according to the official site in the
trailers for starters it's going to be
an open world like seriously an actual
open world or more so than the past
games arceus was very close to this but
similarly to sword and shield it had
borders and loading screens between
towns which apparently won't be the case
here which sounds awesome according to
game freak various towns will blend
seamlessly into the wilderness without
borders you can see pokemon in the sky
seas forest streets and all over but
that's not all to help you explore this
new large open world gamefreak
introduces multiplayer you can play with
up to four players and explore which
okay has me seriously excited sword and
shield did have some fun multiplayer but
only in match made raid battles in
addition to the typical usual one-on-one
battling or trading features
unfortunately we don't know the nature
of the open world and how online
connectivity will properly work and i am
a little hesitant but cautiously
optimistic
i love pokemon and i grew up with the
series a lot so to be able to play with
my friends or colleagues that still play
yeah it's gonna be fun no matter what we
also get to meet some new characters one
of them is your friend nimona an
experienced trainer who will guide you
throughout your adventure and we also
meet the pokemon professors you have
professor sarah or professor turo and
for the first time they are version
exclusive they certainly look younger
and cooler than your typical professor
oak or rowan and one of them even
um kinda looks like
yeah
so i'm sure the overall plot of gen9
games will be no different than before
the professors will give you a pokedex
most likely and task you with traveling
all over the region to catch or see them
all and take on the pokemon league
so now you guys have to let me know how
you're feeling about the news so far are
y'all team sprightito like me what
regional variants do you hope to see and
how do we feel about professor chat i
mean professor turo
and which version are you guys gonna get
let me know in the comments below for
everything else pokemon stick with
gamespot until next time
[Music]
you